apple's new macbooks are a massive
upgrade from the previous intel max but
they are not perfect and even though
they brought back the ports made a huge
jump in both performance and battery
life and have shockingly good displays
they still have some weaknesses and
still suck at certain things so after
two months of daily use i want to cover
those areas where the new macbook still
lacking which is causing some people to
hold on to their intel max or buy
windows laptops instead so as you guys
know we are huge mac fans but that
doesn't mean that we don't talk about
the negatives and the downsides and even
though we made a top 10 problems video a
month ago most of those problems are
still valid and no i am not just gonna
be talking about those things in this
video these are new and unique so let's
go ahead and jump in the first one has
to be the lack of boot camp having the
ability to run windows was something
that sold a lot of people on previous
macs since if an app wasn't available
for mac os you could simply boot into
windows and run it but with these apple
silicon macbooks that is no longer
possible it is actually because of this
that i don't have imacs at home but
instead have a couple of windows pcs for
my kids to use and game on now believe
it or not the reason why the new
macbooks don't have windows bootcamp
support is actually because of microsoft
themselves apple said that everything is
ready to go and they are waiting on them
but it turns out microsoft made a secret
exclusivity deal with qualcomm for
windows arm but thankfully that deal is
coming to an end soon and should open up
support now the real question is if
microsoft will actually allow windows to
be installed on these macs because that
will drive less sales to pc devices if
windows can be installed on macs that
are superior in most ways to their pc
counterparts especially the m1 macbook
air which cost less than their
equivalent windows laptops while being
faster and having much better battery
life for now you can use parallels to
set up a windows virtual machine which
we show how in our guide but you then
have to use the limited developer
preview arm version of windows which has
its own limitations with that we have
the next weakness and this time is
completely apple's fault and that is
gaming as we know these new macbooks can
be extremely fast for gaming smoking
even the best graphics card in the
latest 27 inch imac but that is only if
the games support both our versions of
mac os and are optimized for metal gfx
bench shows how well these macs can run
being super close to an rtx 3080 and the
same thing goes for 3dmark's latest
cross-platform test wildlife extreme
what is even crazier is that the m1 max
only uses up to 46 watts in a 16-inch
macbook and usually runs at about 43 at
100 load whereas the rtx 3080 is best
optimized at
105 watts and the 165 watt full power
version isn't actually that much more
powerful and if you unplug one of those
machines they drop down to a similar 46
watts but with way less performance than
the m1 max but with that said when it
comes to actual gaming only a handful of
good games actually perform similarly to
an rtx 3080 we have world of warcraft
eve online baldur's gay 3 and x plane
11. now there are also apple arcade
games that have better graphics for
their mac variants such as asphalt but
in reality 99 of games don't run well on
these new macbooks as anthony from linus
tech tips pointed out even mac os games
that are optimized for metal still
perform shockingly bad with the new 14
and 16 inch macbook pros sometimes being
barely faster than the m1 chip and that
is because of rosetta these games are
designed for x86 intel processors and
even though rosetta did a great job with
the m1 max we now know that for gaming
rosetta cannot keep up with the high
performance m1 pro and m1 max graphics
and severely limits it and if gaming
wasn't bad enough in the past with apple
dropping support for opengl and not
supporting vulkan which nvidia amd intel
and qualcomm do
which means that developers had to make
intel versions they now also have to
compile for arm as well so it is even
tougher for aaa games to be optimized
for these new macbooks and the old ones
run poorly for now you need a lot of
workarounds to get games to run
minecraft has a big process rocket
league requires workarounds with wine
crossover 21 works for some games like
gta 5 but we still had to turn the
settings way down because of rosetta and
new games with anti-cheat like call of
duty simply don't work we'll either have
to wait for windows games to be designed
for arm and then be optimized for metal
or for apple to pay developers a lot of
money to properly port those over with
that we have other software that doesn't
run well or straight up doesn't work now
i have to preface this and say that the
vast majority of software has been
updated and it was updated way faster
than people expected even adobe who is
slow with optimizations has updated most
of their software including premiere pro
which performs shockingly well like
matthew money showed in his video
comparing the m1 max to a custom alder
lake pc with an rtx 3080 and a 14 inch
macbook beat out that desktop in puget
bench's test which tests a wide variety
of different things in that software and
the same thing goes for photo editing
video editing coding music production
and most plugins now the software is
optimized and it's super fast so for
most people these macs run great but we
do still have other things that are
taking a while to update such as
applications for a cad design like
solidworks for mac and visual studio
even simple software like evernote and
dropbox haven't been updated yet and i
don't know how they say it will take
until up to mid of next year when these
macs have been out for over a year
already and along with that lots of
software that does show up as native
still needs additional optimization for
example redshift where the new macbooks
are way slower than its nvidia
competition and in general 3d rendering
has always been a weak spot for max and
even though it's going to be way faster
with these new macs it is still not
going to lead in this area blender just
added support and it is way faster than
before over five times in some of my
tests which ended up getting close and
even matching up to an rtx 3080 laptop
using cuda even though this is the very
first alpha release and it will get
faster and of course because of the
insane power efficiency of these macs
they can do this on battery whereas
unplugging a high-end windows pc causes
the performance to plummet with that
said even though these rtx graphics
cards were released years before apple
silicon was even announced programs are
still optimizing for them and we also
got a new version of blender that can
use ray tracing cores which was not
working in the version i tested in my
latest 3d rendering comparison so thank
you guys for giving me the tips on how
to set it up properly which honestly it
should be preset out of the box this way
and also telling me to not use the gpu
ncp rendering because the gpu only is
actually faster as i verified myself
with these new optimizations the nvidia
cars now use ray tracing cores and man
are they fast instead of taking 30
seconds for the bmw scene it only took
12 with opti x ray tracing being close
to 3 times faster than the mac using
metal and in the classroom project
instead of taking just four seconds
faster than the 60-inch m1 max with
opt-x it is now exactly four times
faster taking just 26 seconds in the
fastest gpu only mode now of course this
is the alpha version of metal and it is
clearly going to get faster but it still
will not match a cheaper nvidia laptop
with rtx graphics and apple gpus do not
have hardware ray tracing at all so
don't expect magical results in the
future with that we have to talk about
raw power yes the m1 max can smoke the
best windows laptops in what they are
optimized for which is quite a lot
actually due to the dedicated media
hardware which makes video editing
insanely fast or the tile memory with
crazy bandwidth which makes photo
editing and coding super fast but when
it comes to a raw graphics grunt pc
laptops still win out looking at
geekbench 5 the 3080 smokes the m1 max
and even though the rtx car does get
beat in many real world tasks when it
comes down to things that need raw power
like denoising raw video it still shows
a big performance lead over the m1 max
now of course you have to be plugged in
to get the full performance but let's be
honest if you're going to be doing this
or 3d rendering most people will be
plugged in the majority of the time and
apple isn't really a company that puts
out an insane desktop gpu into a macbook
and it only offers that performance if
it is plugged in apple always have
designed their laptops to perform the
same whether it is plugged in or
unplugged which for most cases is a
great thing you don't lose performance
but in certain times like raw massive
power they do not compete with high-end
rtx cards and with that the last thing
that i want to cover is egpus because
that is exactly what mac owners would do
to get crazy raw power when they are at
their desk and plugged in but with these
new macbooks you cannot use a egpu
anymore so you're limited to the power
that is in your laptop of course for
most people including myself these new
macbooks are more than powerful enough
but for people doing really tough things
that need raw gpu power these macbooks
will still suck compared to a high-end
windows pc or even an intel macbook with
one or two egpu's attached so there you
guys go these are the areas where the
macbook's still struggling let me know
if you have any other software that's
not working or other things that you
think they need to improve in or apple
needs to fix down in the comments
section below definitely check out our
top 10 problems video there's the other
there's a lot of other additional
information in vadim's video it is great
click that circle above to subscribe to
help us reach our goal of 1 million
subscribers this been max and i'll see
you in the next video
[Music]